[موسيقى]
نرحب بكل المشاهدين كل ضيوف البرنامج الذي
لا تشاهدونهم على الشاشه وكالعاده يمكنكم
ان تتفاعلوا مع مايقولون طيله البرنامج
على صفحتنا على فيسبوك او على صفحه
البرنامج على تويتر
في باريس في حضور ممثلين عن 46 دوله الى
جانب رجال اعمال ورؤساء شركه
عبر الفيديو اتمنى جمع 800 مليون يورو وهي
كاترينا وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه تعلن عن
جمع مليار يورو الهدف هو مساعده الشعب
الاوكراني على مواجهه البرد القارس ولكن
ما فاعليه المساعدات وعمليه القصف الروسي
لم تتوقف اوكرانيا تحتاج الى مساعده طرفيه
ام الى اعاده اعمار حقيقيه بعد تحقيق
السلام زيننسكي ماده يدعو للتفاوض والكريم
رد بانه لا تف اعتراف كيف بكل المناطق
التي تم ضمها كيف الخروج من هذه الحلقه
المفرقه سعيد بان يناقش هذا الموضوع مالي
في الاستوديو المحلل السياسي طارق وهبي
سعيد بان يكون معي من الكويت ايفان سيدا
وهو دبلوماسي اوكراني وسعيد بان يكون معي
من لندن مصطفى البزركان ومباحث في
الاقتصاد
السياسي اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا
البرنامج نستمع الى ما قاله الرئيس بما
نويل ماكرون خلال افتتاح هذا المؤتمر
الوقت الراهن يفرض علينا الوضع الطارئ ان
ندعم قدره الشعب الاوكرانيه على الصمود من
اجل ان تتجاوز اوكرانيا هذا الشتاء الطويل
بالاضافه الى ما سبق تقديمه الى 125 مليون
يورو كمساعده عاجله
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للغذاء وسبعه عشر مليون للصحه
22 مليون للنقل
المتبقي بحث
سيده من الكويت غير امسكي طالبه ب 800
مليون يورو حصل على مليار يورو اوكرانيا
في حاجه الى مساعدات ظرفيه بسبب موسم
الشتاء ام في حاجه الى مساعده دائمه
واعاده اعمار والعوده الى السلام
انتصار الاوكراني واخراج القوات المسلحه
الروسيه من الكاميرا الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بحدود بها طرف الدوليه فهذا سيخفف بالضغط
على ليس فقط على اوروبا ولكن العالم خاصه
في موضوع
الغذائي وهكذا
سيؤمن اوروبا من ان روسيا لا تتمكن من
هجوم عليها كما هجمت على اوكرانيا
وبالنسبه للاعمار في حاله الحرب نحن
متفاهمين جيدا مع هذه الاوضاع وفعلا هذه
الحرب بدات في 2000 2014
روسيا وحتى الاستثمارات في اوكرانيا خلال
هذه الفتره طويله لم تتوقف همم اما الان
الحرب الشامله همم
في اطار خاصه في ظل الشطاء الفارس وروسيا
مؤتمد يعني عمدا تقصف المنشات الطاقه
لتاثير
ليكون اكثر على الجمهور في اوكرانيا فبطبع
هذا يسمى ارهابا طبقا
لمصطلح القانوني اما اوكرانيا بحاجه الى
المساعده وهذا كذلك سيخفف بالضغط على
الدول الاوروبيه
عدم المزيد باكس يعني المزيد من النزوح
الاوكرانيين الى هذه الدول وروسيا طعمه
كذلك هذا الموضوع
وثانيا بالنسبه لاوكرانيا همم الان همم
فعلا همم تم تقويه الدفاع الجوي وهذا
سيحني ليس فقط المنشات المدنيه ولكن خاصه
الانشاءات حيويه في البنيه تحتيه
لامتدادات الطاقه
اخرها واخيرا اذا سمحتم همم هذه
اعمار في ظل الحرب سيصاعد في صمود
للاقتصاد الاوكراني وكذلك اي استثمار
حاليا او
اجرا او اجلا في اوكرانيا وهو استثمار في
الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه اوكرانيا همم الان
يدفع ثمانا بالضم من اجل اختيار وحريه
الاختيار لمصيرها ال- ال- السياسه
الخارجيه وانضمامها الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهممته طيب مصطفى البزره كان عندما نتحدث
عن مليار يورو هو مبلغ يعني قليل جدا خاصه
عندما نرى ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا والحديث عن
اكثر من 1000 مليار دولار فقط لاعاده
الاعمار ونحن الان الحرب لن تتوقف ومع ذلك
اذا هذه المساعدات الظرفيه اقتصاديا على
سبيل المثال هل يمكن ان تكون نافعا
للمواطنين
المليار يورو التي تم يعني تقديمها اليوم
كان نصفها توجه الى مساعدات انيه ويظهر
انه ابواب المساعدات الامنيه المحتاجه
اللي تحتاجها الرئيس الاوكراني لم لم تكن
مقدمه ولذلك هذا المبلغ هو نصف المبلغ
الذي قال به الرئيس الاوكراني هذه نقطه
النقطه الثانيه هذه الملياردو يضاف الى
93.8 مليار يورو تم تقديمها الى اوكرانيا
وهذا تقريبا موثق من معهد كيف للدراسات
هذه نقطه ثانيه نقطه ثالثه همم ما يمكن
انه همم
يحافظ على الاقتصاد الاوكراني طبعا
الاقتصاد الاوكراني خلال العام القادم
سيتعرض الى انكماش بحدود 35% يحتاج حسب
توقيت صندوق النقد الدولي الى اكثر من
435 مليار يورو هذه جميعا حينما ن كارقام
نرى انه الحاجه هي ليست الحاجه الامنيه
فقط وانما حتى حاجه على مدى بعيد ولكن
حينما ذلك
سيتوضح حينما تهدئ المدافع وتقف الحرب اما
باستمرار هذه الحرب فانا اعتقد انه صحيح
وسؤالك عوده الى سؤالك بالنسبه للمواطن
طبعا همم عدد نفوس اوكرانيا بحدود 42
مليون هناك سته عشر مليون نصفهم في
الاتحاد الاوروبي هجروا ونصرهم مهجرين في
داخل اوكرانيا هذه جميعا ودول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لم تقصر وتقدم ما يمكنها رغم انه
هناك لا ننساه هناك ازمه اقتصاديه تضرب كل
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك تضخم مرتفع
هناك همم يعني همم بوادر على ركود اقتصادي
مع ذلك الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي تقدم ما
يمكنها تقديم او اكثر ولذلك انا اعتقد هذه
المساعدات الماليه لن تتوضح تاثيراتها
فاجا الا بعد ايقاف الحرب طيب ترقاوي يعني
طبعا المقارنه مثل ما اقول بالفرنسيه يكون
بارزوني باريزون وقارن ليس لها علاقه
بالعقل ولكن اذا ما اردنا ان نقارن مع
لبنان على سبيل المثال عدد الدول التي
شاركت
مرسيدس والمبلغ 9 مليار 9 مليار يورو يورو
9 مليار يورو بينما لاوكرانيا مليار وعدد
السكان في لبنان
خلينا دعنا نبدا من الاول عندما رجع
الرئيس مكروه من امريكا كان هناك نوع من
ياس لان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليست
جاهزا لمن نسميه مؤتمر سلام
وللاسف الشديد ما يحصل الان هو عباره عن
مؤتمرات انسانيه تستطيع الامم المتحده ان
تقوم بها وليس الدوله الفرنسيه الجميل
بالموضوع ان استطاع الرئيس مكروم ان يجب
من كمبوديا رئيس وزراء كامبوديا كان
موجودا في فرنسا بهذا المؤتمر يعني رئيس
مكرونه يلعب على ما نسميه الكره الارضيه
او على الدول في العالم لكي تتحد وكيف
تكون واحده امام ما نسميه مساعدته اوكراني
انا برايي الان كل ما سافر دول الخليج
شارك يعني بعطيك عم بعطيك عن الموضوع فقط
كمبوديا ما ما معنى ان تكون كمبوديا
موجوده في هذا الاجتماع هو اساس ما معنى
ان تكون اندونيسيا الدوله التي كانت منظمه
لدول 2020 هي موجوده اذا الرئيس مكرونه
يبحث عن ما نسميه نوع من الداخليه
دبلوماسيه لانه هذا المؤتمر حقيقه الامم
المتحده قادره ان تقوم به لان هذا مؤتمر
انساني لانه حتى العنوان متضامنون مع
الشعب الاوكراني ليس بالمفهوم السياسي الا
حضور السيد الاولى الاوكرانيه التي
بحضورها نحن امام ما نسميه الوجه المناضل
الحقيقي بصفه ان الرئيس سيلانسكي الذي هو
يذهب حتى الى ابعد حد يعني عندما ذهب الى
المناطق التي حررت حاليا اظهر ان لا يزال
لدي هذا الشعب الاوكراني القوه في القتال
ولكن بنفس الوقت
اوكرانيا تطلب اكثر بكثير مما تريد يعني
همم الدكتور من لندن قال في تقرير البنك
الدولي يمكن من شهرين بدهم 380 مليار
دولار
ولكن انا برايي لا يمكن ان اتحدث عن اعداد
اعاده اعمار لطالما الصواريخ الروسيه تقصف
نستطيع
ما المشكله
عن الجغرافيا الحاليه لاوكرانيا لانه هناك
جغرافيا للاسف هناك من يفكر بالحل الكوري
بمعنى اقتطاع اوكرانيا غربيه رانيا شرقيه
وقول للرئيس بوتين اننا انتهينا من هذا
الموضوع هل تستطيع ان تقبل بذلك يعني لذلك
الرئيس زيلانسكي خائف جدا مما يحصل الان
لانه لا يريد ان يحصل تحت الطاوله ما بين
كل هذه القوه الكبيره في العالم ان يكون
يعني نوعا ما السلام على ماذا على حساب
اوكرانيا لذلك انا برايي هذا المؤتمر جيد
ولكن تستطيع الامم المتحده القيام به ليست
مشكله فرنسا ان تقوم على فرنسا ان تصدر
قرارات بالمفهوم السياسي هو قال انا اريد
ان احادثتين لم يحدث بوتين حتى بوتين لا
يريد المحادثه مع احد الرئيس الفرنسي همم
الدول التي كانت تريد ضمن ما نسميه مجموعه
ال 20 موضوع مجموعه الحكماء بمعنى الصين
فرنسا تركيا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
للعمل على فتح طريق للسلام في اليوم همم
الذي تلى هذا الاقتراح ارسل بوتين 100
صاروخ ومنهم الصاروخ الذي ااه ضرب بمنطقه
لفيف والتي الى بولونيا يعني نحن امام
مشكله لها علاقه بالمفهوم الحل العسكري
ومشكله علاقه بالحل السياسي ونطرح مواضيع
لها علاقه يعني ما ما معنى ان نرسل 100 او
200 مولد كهربائي لكي ننير اوكرانيا وبنفس
الوقت لا توجد همم وقود لا توجد صيانه
لهذه يعني هناك نوعا ما همم نوع من همم
يعني همم تناقض بالمساعده وبنفسك انا افهم
مساعدات الغذائيه انا افهم المساعدات
الطبيه ولكن لاناره المدن التي لم يوجد
فيها كهرباء نفس المولدات هذه المولات
بحاجه الوقود من اين تاتي النقود وهذا هو
المشكله ايفان لا هذا هو المشكله هو توفير
الامكانيات
بالطبع نحن
[موسيقى]
كذلك كل
الاعمال
هناك وقود تصل سعره غالي الانسي اوكرانيا
او دولار و20 سنه وهذا اييه
العائله العاديه عندما تشتري المولد
كهربائي ويجب ان تشتري كذلك هذا الوقود
ولكن
في اوكرانيا هذه الامدادات
الكهربائيه اول شيء يجب توفير من اجل
همم
بني التحكيع الحيويه
للشباب همم عيش دون كهرباء فهو معاناه
ولكن بالنسبه للكبار وكبار السن والاطفال
الصغار او مرضى فهذا قد يكون البطيء همم
ايه بعيدا ان اتحدث عن جرائم الحرب
والارهاب من النظام الروسي الارهابي ولكن
منطقيا اوكرانيا بحاجه الى هذا الى اي
مساعده التي خاصه يعني الان بعد المؤتمر
في باريس بملياردولار او كذلك بالمساعدات
الانسانيه من الدول الاخرى من اجل الصمود
وهذا همم روسيا هي الان همم تتحدث عن مثل
ما هي تريد المحادثات همم وهي تحاول اطاله
هذه الحرب ولكن في الحقيقه نحن نعلم شهيد
ان التاريخ
عندما بعد هذه همم سبع سنوات تهاج روسيا
من جديد
سنوات
عندما كانت الحربين اثنين على الحرب
الاولى والحربه الثانيه تحت التبرير
الزائف عندما هاجم روسيا لاحتلال هذه
المنطقه بشكل كامل وبط روسيا لن تتخلى بعد
عن
الاحتلال كامل لاوكرانيا ولا يوجد هناك اي
اتفاق حول التقسيمه اوكرانيا رفضت هذا
تماما ونحن نصير الى حقنا وعلى احترام
الميثاق الامم الامم المتحده وانا ساقول
لكم اينما متى سنحتاج هذا همم 1,000 مليار
دولار طبقا لبعض الاحصائيات ولكن انا همم
افضل حاليا ان اتحدث عن الرقم
39 مليار دولار التي تم اثباته من طرف همم
اوكرانيا وكذلك همم
الارقام او ارقام اكبر من ذلك في حاله
الحرب في هذه الارقام تزداد ولكن نحن
صرناش على روسيا لدفع هذه التعويضات هذا
لن يكون عباره
الواقع غير مختلف يا استاذ يا استاذ ايفان
مليار يورو مليار يورو كيف تريد ان توصل
الوقود الى اوكرانيا الان والطرق من من
بولونيا ومن رومانيا في هناك مشاكل الان
درجه الحراره في كيف هي الا 13 مدري الا
20 تريد هذه المساعدات ان تصل غدا هل
حقيقه هل هناك واقعيه بكل ما يحصل انا
برايي نحن امام همم يعني للاسف الشديد ما
اسميه همم سيناريو همم فقط لمؤتمر المؤتمر
ولا توجد ما نسميه الاليات الارضيه
الاليات التي لها علاقه بتنفيذ كل ما صدر
يعني وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه تقول 500
هنا و300 هنا و200 هنا ولكن في الحقيقه
كيف سنصل الى ما هي الخطه المتبعه لا احد
يجاوب الوقود
مصطفى
عبر الانترنت سيكون هناك تقديم لحاجه
ماليه او اي حاجه اخرى ويتم الاجابه عليها
فورا بمعنى انه لن يكون هناك اي مشكله
امام اي طلب من اوكرانيا ودائما الضيوف
الكارورون مليار يورو ليست مليار يورو هي
اربعه اصبحت 94 وثمانيه بالعشره من
المليار يعني اربع سنين مليار يورو قدم
لنهايه هذا الشهر ليست مليار لماذا نقول
مليار ولذلك هناك 52 مليار المتحده من
الدول الاوروبيه قدمت 25 مليار بريطانيا
اثنين ونصف مليار جنيه هذه جميعها ارقام
لابد انه نعلم ويعمل من يقدمها اين تذهب
صحيح صحيح ونحن نحن صامدين في اوكرانيا
عندما كانت جميع الخبراء وحتى الخبراء
اوكرانيون واوروبيون يتوقعون ان وكيل
سيسقط بعد اسبوعين في الحاله المتفائله
ومتشائمون كان يقولون عن الكيس سيسقط بعد
ثلاثه ايام لم يتحقق ذلك ونحن صامدين
والوقود فعلا تصل عبر الرومانيه اكثر شيء
اعتقد عبر رومانيا الى البحر والمواصلات
بالطرق اقرب بهذه المنطقه همم والوقود
متوفر في مدينه كيف وامي وابي يعيشون هناك
همم كل يوم يشترون هذا الوقود في لو كان
بسعر اعلى بالطبع مقارنه قبل الحرب ولكن
هو متوفر وبالنسبه ل- اا الصمود اهم شيء
هذا الان ان تصمد اوكرانيا امام هذه الحرب
العدوانيه الروسيه وبعد ذلك انا
اتفق معكم في ان هذه الاشعارات السياسيه
اجبار روسيا للدفع للدفع تعويضات الحرب
اولا بالطبع يجب تحرير كامل الاراده
الاوكرانيه وبعد ذلك يجب ابقاء على البقاء
العقوبات الدوليه حتى روسيا تتفق على همم
على دفع العقوبات جميعا مثل ما عملت
العراق دوله الكويت عندما هاجمت
العراق ليس عضو دائم في مجلس الامم
المتحده ولكن بالنسبه لروسيا انا متاكد
عندما تنتصر اوكرانيا وتحرر ولو قال شفت
جزيره القرم او مدينه او مدينه دهنتك
الرد جاء على لسان الكريم لانه ما فيش ولا
يمكن
تفضل تفضل تفضل تفضل يا مصطفى
تتكلمون عن صحه الوقود يوم امس
روسيا ارسلت 42 مليون متر مكعب من الغاز
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر اوكرانيا
لماذا هذا يعبر الى الاتحاد
في اوكرانيا انا لا افهم ذلك يرجى توضيح
لماذا كيف يعمل هذا الغازي للاتحاد
الاوروبي وهناك شيحه
انا واضح لكم حتى حقيقه حتى الان عبر
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الغاز الروسي تعبر
باتجاه الاتحاد الاوروبي مثلما مثلا كدوله
هنغاريا او بعض الدول الافريقي ونحن
اوكرانيا
وخلفائنا في الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن نحن
نصير ان يتم في اقرب وقت رفض من شراء
الغاز والبترول الروسي
حتى يكون الوقت للدول الاتحاد الاوروبي في
تنويرها
تاثير السلبي على تصادها ونحن نتفاهم جيدا
ان تاثير سلبي موجود قوي جدا الاقتصاد
الاوروبي يعاني من هذه المشكله ولكن
اوكرانيه اكبر واوكرانيا اصبحت كدمان
اوروبا لان روسيا لن تتمكن من الهجوم على
اي بلد على موضوع يعني الموضوع اكيد هي
خطبه ثانيه
هناك منطقه
اليوم في اوروبا هناك صوت جديد صوت يقول
نحن نريد ان ندافع ان اوكرانيا نحن نريد
ان ندعم اوكرانيا ولكن كل هذه الارتدادات
التي تصل الى اوروبا بالمفهوم الاقتصادي
اهلكت الخليه الاولى التي هي البيت داخل
الاوروبي يعني اليوم في اوروبا انت تعرف
جيدا ان فاتوره الطاقه ارتفعت انت تعرف
حتى موضوع الغذاء ارتفع المشكله ليست
بالمفهوم الدعم السياسي لاوكراني المشكله
انه مثل ما قال الدكتور مصطفى لا يزال يمر
الغاز الى اوروبا لانه هناك مصالح واوروبا
تدفع حاسه من هذا الغاز وبنفس الوقت حضرتك
تقول عليكم ان توقف هذا هذه المشتريات من
روسيا حتى اللحظه لا توجد اتفاقات داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي بهذا المفهوم يعني
الاتفاق الوحيد اللي وصله هو تسعير همم
سعر النفط القادم من روسيا واتفق عليه
الاوروبيين وبمضاض يعني لمرحله معينه
انا برايي الان
لا ينفع هذا المؤتمر الا بالمفهوم
الانساني لاننا بحاجه لهذا الموضوع وانا
اعطيتك يعني مثل بسيط انت تذهب بمولد الى
مدينه في اوكرانيا اذا كانت البنيه
التحتيه الكهربائيه دمرت دمرتها الروس
عليك ان تبني بنيه جديده هذه البنيه
الجديده تتطلب ايضا صيانه تتطلب وقود
لاشغال هذا المولد نحن امام ليس مشكله شهر
يعني اقله شهرين يعني سناء يعني سنخرج من
الشتاء عندما ستصل هذه المساعده هو جيد ان
تكون هناك مساعدات ولكن مشكله توقيت ذلك
انا برايي غير صحيح كان يجب ان يبدا ذلك
في شهر سبتمبر لكي نصل الى هذا الموضوع
وليس الان في هذا في في المطلوب اما
بالنسبه لما يقول الدكتور مصطفى عن
المساعده هناك مساعدات عسكريه دكتور مصطفى
تصل الى الى مئات المليارات لا نتحدث عنها
ولكن المساعدات الانسانيه او المساعدات
الاقتصاديه هل تعلم ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يدعم ما نسميها الحكومه وانا رواتب
الحكومه الاوكرانيه بمستوى تقريبا 2 مليار
يورو يعني
لانه لا يوجد لا يوجد اي حركه مردوده
اقتصادي اوكراني في الداخل 30 بالمئه نسبه
بطاله في اوكرانيا الان كل هذا يجب علينا
ان نصمت يجب علينا ان ندافع ولكن بنفس
الوقت يجب ايضا ان اكلان ان يفهموا ان بدا
في اوروبا طيار يسال وليست تيار الذي يعني
تعتقدون انه اليمين مطرف ابدا هناك
من الشعب تقول ان نحن نريد ان ندافع عن
حريه نريد ان ندافع عن حقنا بالوجود وان
لا تكون دوله كبرى من روسيه او غير روسيا
تتعد علينا ولكن بنفس الوقت
لا توجد هذه القطر التي تستطيع ان تعطينا
ايضا ايقاف هذه
كلمه اخيره فقط حضرتك ذكرت ااا عن موضوع
الكويت والعراق لا تنسى يا سيدي لا تنسى
انه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تعطي
فلسا في الحرب العالميه الثانيه فقط
المانيا اعطت للدول التي تضررت والولايات
المتحده
الاعلاميه الثانيه كذلك بفضل امريكا
طيب اتفضل مصطفى وعندي سؤال ليك طبعا
يوضح نقطه الاقتصادي الالماني يعتمد على
55% من الغاز الروسي حينما كان يصله
باربعه دولار بكل مليون وحده حراريه
المانيا اليوم تشتري نفس الكميه ب 36
دولار لماذا لانه هناك استراتيجيه فرضت
على المانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي للتخلص من
الاعتماد على النفط والغاز اي اكثر تضحيه
من ذلك هناك ثمانيه مليون اوكراني في دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي من بريطانيا الى ايطاليا
الى كافه الدول هؤلاء هؤلاء همم
موافقه للبقاء لمده سنتين للعمل هناك 800
استرليني تعطى لكل من يسكن معه همم شخص من
اوكرانيا هذه جميعها م- يعني جاءت في وقت
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعاني من مشكلات
اقتصاديه ويستمر يعاني وسيعاني اكثر ولذلك
كان اعتقد لابد ان تكون الصوره واضحه لا
يتم دفع ودفع ودفع وطلب ودفع الى متى لحين
ما تنتهي هذه الحرب وسنرى ماذا ستكون
النتائج منها
يعني اريد ان اتواصل مع ما قاله ايضا طارق
طارق وهبي بمساله وجهه او موقف العديد من
الاوروبيين من مساله اعاده الاعمار ولا
علاقه دوله باليمين متطرف ولا باي شيء لكن
بدانا نسمع هذا الخطاب ان دافع الضرائب هو
الذي سيدفع الثمن الى متى ستستمر هذه
الحرب كم سندفع كذه الخسائر نحن نتكبدها
باعتبار انه غلاء المعيشه غلاء الطاقه
مشكله في انقطاع الكهرباء الان حديد حتى
في فرنسا على احتمال تعرض العديد من المدن
انقطاع في التيار الكهربائي كل هذه بدات
هذه التساؤلات تطرح والناس يطالب
المجال الاول وهو انه الحكومات الاوروبيه
بريطانيا كذلك تدفع مباشره مساعدات وهيبات
الى الحكومه الاكرانيه هذا جانب من يتحمل
وهي تحمله دافع الضرائب الجانب الاخر هذا
التضخم اللي بيحصل التضخم في اسعار الوقود
الغاز همم اصبحت اسعارها اربعه اضعاف
النفط كذلك هذه ايضا لن يدفعها يدفعها
المواطن والديك كل شيء عندنا
11% تضخم فلكي لن تنشده الدول الاوروبيه
هناك بوادر على ركود اقتصادي البنك
المركزي يرفع الفوائد هذه جميعا من يدفعها
من يدفع ثمنها يدفع ثمن
هذه جميعا لابد من ايجاد حل يعني مع هذا
المؤتمر الذي تستضيف فيه باريس لابد ان
يكون هناك مؤتمرات اخرى لمعرفه راي الشارع
الاوروبي في معرفه المواطن الارض الذي هو
يتحمل هذه المساله ماليه وقت اقتصاديه
تفضل ضيفي من الكويت
الان في الوضع افضل بكثير من قناه من
مكانها وضع اوكرانيا في فبراير ومارس الان
في ذلك الوقت
مساعدات من امريكا او من اوروبا ام لا نحن
كنا نعتمد بشكل كامل على انفسنا ولم تعطى
هناك اي اسلحه ثقيله لاوكرانيا الا اسلحه
محموله بالجنود وبطبع هي صعدت كثيرا ولكن
ما نرى الان هناك حتى مواقف في اوروبا
تغيرت كثيرا وسماعنا تصريحات ميركل
واستريحات كذلك الرئيس الفرنسي المحترم
المحترم يعني الان لا يوجد
همم ضغط اوكرانيا من اجلي
التناظر انا اراضي او عدم البوتين او دعوه
للمفاوضات على اساس ان اوكرانيا توافق
بشروط روسيه الان اوكرانيا اعتقد انها
تمكن من الاقناع العالم والدول الاوروبيه
اي وقوف للمحادثات حاليا فقد سيعطي روسيا
ل استعاده قوه ها وضرب مره ثانيه ويجب ان
نحلل كيف جار يعيش في روسيا التجنيد والى
اخرها وثانيا هناك الدفاع الجوي في
اوكرانيا اقوى بكثير مقارنه من مقانا في
الصيف هذه السنه همم لوجيسيات تعمل رغم
تصريحات روسيه بان كل دفاع جوي مدمر
ويعني الاف طائرات همم تم اسقاطها الى
اخرها هي كذيب مثل النزيه وكذيب روسيه
اخرى وفعلا الدفائه الجوي وتقويه الدفاع
الجوي سيساهم في الدفاع عن المنشات
المدنيه التي يتم اعاده تعميرها
ثالثا همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي اعطتنا نموذج جيد انها
انه ناجحه في تنويع مصادر الطاقه رغم
غلائها ولكن على كل حال روسيا حاليا اييه
لم تتوقع ذلك ان الاتحاد الاوروبي بهذه
السرعه تتمكن ان ان تنجح في هذه العمليه
ورابعا روسيا ستدفع التطبيقات التعويضات
عندما تحرر اوكرانيا اي منطقه كبيره من
المناطق حتى لو لم يكن تحرير كامل
هذه اللحظه الجبهه ستنهار وهذا همم يجب ان
نذكر تاريخ روسيا في 1916 عندما تغيرت صار
القيصر الروسي وربما سيحدث نفسه شيخ روسيا
وبعد ذلك يكون اسهل لتحرير كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اوتوماتيكيه الروس
ترهلون على ثروه على ثوره داخليه في روسيا
هذا ممكن هذا ممكن
ولكن
[موسيقى]
انت
ذهبت بعيدا في هذا الموضوع
واسمح لي يعني بقولك ان استطاعت اوكرانيا
ان تصمت في شهريش يعني
وهذا لان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي كان قد درب حدثا كبيرا
من افراد الجيش الاوكراني لان كان هناك من
المخابرات البارطانيه ومن المخابرات
الامريكيه ان الرئيس بوتين سيقوم بشيء ماء
لذلك كان هناك ترقق في هذا الموضوع وهذا
ما ادى الى عدم دخول الى كيف بهذه السرعه
وهذا ما ادى الى هذا الصمود العسكري المهم
الذي وصل اليه ولكن لا تستطيع ان تقول ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم يقدموا هم
بالاول بداوا في هذا الموضوع ويكملون في
هذا الموضوع والان الحاله الصحيحه عسكريه
افضل بكثير افضل بكثير لان
هناك تدريبات الجيش هناك همم اكثر من هيك
اوكرانيين اكثر من ما يكون هناك خارج من
اوكرانيين في داخل الاوكراني بمعنى بمفهوم
التدريب والقتال
ويجب ان نفهم جيدا ان الان ماذا يريد
العالم يريد طاوله حوار تصل الى السلام هل
هذه المؤتمرات تساعد في السلام انا براي
ابدا وان انا قلت منذ بدا ان حتى حضور
السيد الاولى الاوكرانيه في فرنسا وذهابها
الى مدرسه للقاء اطفال اوكران مع زوجه
الرسول في في هذه المدرسه ما هو الا نوع
من همم رساله الى الاوكران ان الوضع هو
صعب جدا وسيستمر انا باعتقادي همم بوتين
لن يترك هذا الموضوع وبوتين سيكمل ممكن ان
تطلب حضرتك وغيرك ان يكون هناك من يقوم
بالثوره داخل الكرم حتى اللحظه انا لا
اراها لا ارى هذه الثوره همم التي
تريدونها ولكن
همم لك الحق ما تقول ان ان يكون هناك
تغيير كما في روسيا يقولون ان علينا تغيير
زنسكي وهذا زينسكي هو المصارع على ما يحصل
في الحديث يجب ان نكون واقعيين والواقع
حاليا يتطلب ان نذهب الى ما نسميه قواعد
مشتركه لكي نصل الى مؤتمر سلام القواعد
المشتركه ليست المخابرات الامريكيه
والمخابرات الروسيه التي تجتمع في تركيا
على ظهر اوكرانيا
طيب مصطفى مصطفى مصطفى راكان
جميل نعناع اعتقد ال- ال- المجتمع الدولي
يحتاج الى مؤتمر سلام ولكن السلام لابد ان
ياتي من اصحاب القرار سواء في روسيا وحتى
في اوكرانيا لم نشهد لحد اليوم دعوه
حقيقيه للسلام يعني هذه هذه نقطه اساسيه
نقطه ثانيه
امين اوكرانيا حتى الرئيس الاوكراني دائما
يطلب مساعدات ولكن هل طلب السلام ما هي
الشروط السلامه المقبوله لابد من هناك الى
هناك من الجانبين وليس دائما طلب عسكري
وطلب اسلحه و و و هذه هذه نقطه اساسيه
ولذلك هذا يعني اتفق معكم على مؤتمر
السلام هناك نقطه لابد من توضيحاه حرب
اوكرانيا غيرت السياسه العسكريه او غيرت
حتى المقاييس العسكريه في دول النافيه كان
هناك طلب من جانب دار الامريكيه منذ عشر
سنوات لابد ان يكون هناك تخصيص للميزانيه
العسكريه باكثر من اثنين بالمئه من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي لكل دوله المانيا كانت لا
تخصص الا واحد فاصل اثنين بالمئه من
الناتج المحليه الاجمالي الولايه المتحده
وبريطانيا الدوله
اليوم بدات وناكر تحرك عسكري عادت المانيا
الى الى المحيط العسكري هناك تقسيطات
ستبلغ تتجاوز 2% من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي هذه النتيجه اللي حارب اوكرانيا
غيرت حتى الخارطه التشليحيه في دول اوروبا
انا اعتقد انه حان الاوان لتكون هناك
دعوات سلام حقيقيه من اجل مواطنين وروسيا
ومن اجل المواطنين الاتحاد
مواطنين دول العالم العالم كله كل العالم
تاثر في اوكرانيا ثم ساعود الى مصطفى همم
مصطفى البرزخين لانه يريد ان نطرح عليه
سؤالا له علاقه بالاقتصاد تفضل تفضل
فعلا
مجموعه قمه مجموعه العشرين للرئيس
الاوكراني اقترح صيغه الصلاه التي تحتوي
على 10 بنود اا ومن اهمها هو لان النووي
والامر الغذائي وامن الطاقه وبطبع افراج
الجميع الاسرى وتنفيذ نطاق الامم المتحده
وهمم وحده استعاده وحده اراضي اوكرانيا
لابد من ذلك ومنع التسعيد واخيرا سيكون
التاكيد انتهاء الحرب عن طريق اتفاقيه
السلام ونحن لا ناخذ سلام ولكن حاليا اي
محادثات مع روسيا بشان السلام ممنوعه
للقانون طبقا للمرسوم الرئاسي الذي صدر
مباشره بعد همم اعلان روسيا انضم اربع
مرات اوكرانيه ونحن لا نفارق بين او خرسان
ونفس بين قوسين حسن النيه الروسيه في
خرسان انا متاكد نحن نثق في ذلك ان سنرى
هذه الخصم النيه في القرب المناطق الاخرى
واا نحن لا نعتمد على الشعب الروسي الذي
قد يغير الحكومه ولكن او الرئاسه ولكن لا
تتحول قوه عندما طيب هامون واللي جرافات
او اغنياء حول بوتين سيفهمون ان لا يوجد
همم مستقبل روسيا في هذه الظروف مع هذه
السياسه الاقتصاديه والعدوانيه للاخير
سيغيرون هذه الحكومه ونحن يجب ان ان يبقى
هناك عقوبات حتى لحظه اندم روسيا توافق
على دفع التعويضات وهذا لن يكون عبئا على
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذه تعويضات الذي يرجع
استثمار في اوكرانيا هذا سيغني الاتحاد
الاوروبي لانه اوكرانيا
بالقوه يريد انضمام الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا
وهذا ما نرفع سعره حاليا عن طريق الحرب
ولا نوع الحريه والحريه اختيار مصيرنا اه
لا من التوقعات مصطفى كامل اريد ان اسالك
الرهان في البدايه هو على اضعاف الاقتصاد
الروسي واضعف الاقتصاد من شانه انت نجر
انا وتنجو معنا العديد من القرارات بما في
ذلك ربما وقف الحرب حتى الان
هذا الرهان لم ينجح السلاح الاقتصادي لم
ينجح ولكن هل في المقابل هذا السلاح سلاح
تقديم الدعم الى اوكرانيا الى متى سيستمر
وهل سينزح هو الحاء اخر خاصه اذا ما ضعف
الاقتصاد الاخراني
لم يشهدها تاريخ العالم القديم
والاتحاد الاوروبي يعتمد على نفقه الناس
كانت تداعيات هذه العقوبات تاثيراتها اكثر
على الاتحاد الاوروبي من روسيا روسيا
مدخولها من النقط مع نهايه هذا العام هذا
الشهر هو 67 مليار النفط فقط
من الغاز انا اعتقد انه كان الهدف هوك
الاقتصاد الروسي هل يتم ذلك ولكن على
مستوى ابعد واكثر تاثيرا من تاثر همم
تاثيرها على الاقتصاد الاوروبي هذه هذه من
ناحيه لابد من من توضيح نبقى الى النقطه
الثانيه والمهمه وهي انه هل هذه المساعدات
انقذت اوكرانيا انا اعتقد انه هناك
مساعدات عسكريه همم
المستفيد الاكبر من الحرب في اوكرانيا هي
مصانع السلاح هذه نقطه اساسيه والاقتصاد
اللي بيعتمد على المصالح هو المستفيد
الاكبر من هذه الحرب ولذلك شاهدنا هذه
الهبه بتزويد اوكرانيا صحيح صحيح
فعلا هي اسلحه غربيه ولكن دماء اوكرانيه
صحيح ولكن هذه الاداره عجله الاقتصاد الذي
يعتمد على مصانع السلاح ولذلك نعتقد لابد
من وقفه متامنيه تجاه سلام حقيقي ايقاف
هذا وهذه هذه النزيف الاوكراني ولكن بدماء
اوكرانيه وباموال اوروبيه ودوليه
يعني انا اول شيء لا اوافق على موضوع
الطرح اللي طرحته حضرتك فيه يعني العقوبات
اثرت كثيرا اثرت كثير العقوبات
تاثرت كثيرا العقوبات على روسيا والذي
يقول لك ان الروبل لم يعاني الروبل يعاني
والحقيقه الان ان العمله الروسيه هي واقفه
لان الدوله تدعمها ولا تريدها ان تصعر
ولذلك انا برايي عندما تذهب هذه الدوله
التي هي ممثله بالرئيس بوتين والذي حوله
سينهار الروبي اكثر من ذلك انا برايي الان
كل ما ذكر الدكتور مصطفى من تبيعه روسيا
هي موجوده ليست بصندوق روسيا يعني
الموجودات لروسيا في الخارج هي كبيره جدا
والان همم اوكرانيا وانا افهم السيد ايفان
الذي يقول نريد انه تدفع روسيا همم
وهم يطلبون الاتحاد الاوروبي او من الدول
العامه ان تاخذ هذه الاموره تدفعه ولكن
بالقانون الدولي او بالقانون لا تسمى لا
يمكن ذلك يعني لا يمكن ان تتعدى في هذا
الموضوع لكي تصل الى هذه القضيه لذلك انا
براي كل ما تطلبه اوكراني الان هو ان يكون
هناك طاوله للسلام وطاوله السلام تبدا
صحيح بالبنود العشره التي طلبها الرئيس
لينسكي وحقه ان يطلب بنود عشره ولكن لم
نسمع ما يريده الرئيس بوتين والرئيس بوتين
يفكر بنوغاروسيا ما هي نوبي روسيا يعني
على الاقليم الاربعاء ضد اقليم همم ايضا
في همم في في في دول اخرى وهو يريد ان
ينشا ما يسميه هذا هذه
الممر ان يحمي نفسه من هذا الموضوع والان
هذه الفكره تذهب الى الكبار في العالم
يعني الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حتى
اللحظه لا تسمع هي تريد ان تعطي اسلحه
والاقتصاد العسكري لذكر الدكتور مصطفى
يعني ادهك حتى الدول اليوم لا يوجد في
مخازن السلاح الفرنسيه نزل تحت المستوى
الذي تس- يعني وزاره الدفاع تقول انه يجب
ان يكون لان كل هذه الاسلحه والذخائر تذهب
الى اوكرانيا كذلك في دول اخرى اذا اليوم
الاقتصاد العسكري الذي هو اقتصاد الماكينه
التي تنتج السلاح العسكري بدا بشكل رهيب
واا يعني زد على ذلك مثلا موضوع التيارات
المسيره وما تضرب الطائرات مصيرها الان في
اوكرانيا نحن امام حائط كبير اوكرانيا
مصره ولها الحق ان تصير لان هذا تعدي في
القانون الدولي ولكن كيف نصل اذا حل هذا
الموضوع يجب انا برايي قبل السنه مرور سنه
على هذه الحرب الناس الى الحل لانه ابتداء
من شهر اذار سيعود الرئيس الاوكراني الى
همم الى بالقول انهم ساعدوني لان الرئيس
الروسي لا يسمع احد
طيب اذا عندما عندما يكون البلد في حرب
يفترض ان تتوفر فيه كافه الشروط لحسن
استخدام اقتصاد الحرب هل لديكم اليه
الكافيه لاستخدام اقتصاد الحرب
نعم نعم الان هناك يوجد
النظام
الشديد وعلى بالنسبه لتكسير النفقات
الدوله هذا اولا ثانيا هناك في كل مناطق
الذي موجوده في هذه في الجبهه هناك ذلك
همم
مساعده من طرف الحكومه في امدادات
الانسانيه الى هذه همم
المناطق اما اكثر شيء نحن همم نركز على
تمكين الاقتصاد ان يمشي لانه اقتصاد هو
يدفع الضرائب واقتصاد هو يقوم همم
بحركه داخل اوكرانيا وان نحن كذلك اعتمد
على تصدير الحبوب والزراعه والان نحن نعلم
ان تصدير الحديد همم ان قامش كثيرا يعني
همم بسبب احتلال المريوط والمناطق في شرق
اوكرانيا كانت غنيه بالحديد ونحن همم ليس
فقط امر الغذائي في اوكراني ولكن كذلك
الامن الغذائي في العالم همم اولا
وبالنسبه بالنسبه همم
طريقه السلام في اقرب طريق الى السلام
سيكون تقديم اسلحه متطوره لاوكرانيا ايه
من اجل اخراج القوات الروسيه من هناك ونحن
سننهي هذه الحرب اسرع
انفسنا في بدايه هذه الحرب همم
الانتدابات العسكريه كانت شحيحه شحيحه جدا
وحتى الحديث عن الدبابات والطائرات كان
همم
حتى الصواريخ باتريات حسب ما اعلنت عنه
الولايات المتحده
ونحن متاكدين في انتصار اوكرانيا واقتصاد
يجب ان تحرك والان هذه المؤتمرات
الانسانيه
والدعم اوكرانيا هي تصاعد في الصمود ونحن
صديقنا الحدث
هذه وصفه هذه وصفه عسكريه للحرب العالميه
الثالثه لا يمكن الاستمرار فيها وان هناك
سيستعير كلام ابو الدبلوماسيه الامريكي
ثلاث سيناريوهات لاما استمرار هذه الحرب
وان اكل الطرفين وهذه الصدر سنوات
وهي ايقاف الحرب حالا وبالتالي البحث عن
حلول سلميه بعد الهدنه اما استمرار الحرب
فلا يمكن يعني كما قال ضيفكم يعني هذا
تزويده بهذا السلاح هذه الوصفه حرب عالميه
الثالثه بدا القصف والقصف مقابل ولا ننسى
انه روسيا مقابل لها حلف الناتجه وليست
اوكرانيا وقد يكون هناك كما حصل قبل
اسابيع سقوط احد الصواريخ اما صواريخ
اوكرانيه او روسيا على بولندا وكان على
وشك وبولندا لا ننسى هي عضو في حلف
الناتجه هذه ممكن انه يحصل اي خطا في هذه
المواجهه عليه على العالم والراي العام
الدولي ان يطالب وقف اطلاق النار وبالتالي
البحث عنه
لن تهاجم الناطر روسيا لانها خسرت كثيرا
في اوكرانيا وهي ليست قادره الان بالهجوم
على اي دوله ناقه ونحن كذلك رد الفعل
الروسي الانضمام السويسي
ان تضرب في العمق الروسي ما كان هدف هذه
الطائرات المسيره التي ضربت في العمق
الروسي هل هذا هل هذا
هل هذا برايك يفتح الحوار لكي نصل الى
طريقه سلام ابدا اكيد
المجالس بما حرقت نقاش اخرى ولكن الوقت
انتهى الشكر في الختام للمحل سياسي طارق
خوابه شكرا مدينه الكويت لفان سيده
ودبلوماسي اوكراني والشكر من لندن لمصطفى
البذره كان باحث في الاقتصاد السياسي شكرا
لفريق البرنامج همسي مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]